alright hey everybody how you doing
awesome
lively audience Wow yeah y'all get lunch
ok alright
I'm Michael Rogers I'm gonna talk about
nodejs I hope that's what you came for
so node is the fastest-growing
open-source platform in the world it is
the ecosystem just blowing up I give a
lot of talks about nodes growth the
short answer is it's up it's always is
up so right now the ecosystem is more
than twice the size of the next
competitor which is Java it's more than
twice as big as any other open source
ecosystem we're closing in on a half a
million modules pretty soon that'll be
cool every day 500 new packages are
published at NPM which is crazy like a
lot of them are useless but some of them
are very useful and if you're if you
have an idea and you want to go and
implement it you don't have to implement
all of the crazy infrastructure below
that because literally five people
already published different versions of
it most of them just the same version
wrapped in promises so no it has about
seven million users right now that's
that's our current estimate and we're
growing at about a hundred percent
year-over-year we've been growing at a
hundred percent year-over-year for
almost five years now so this is really
really consistent growth at some point
we have to cap out like we're running
out of the entire developer market but
there's no reason to know that they
think that this year we won't double
again and at this time next year at
build will be at about fourteen million
users so when we were trying to figure
out like where is all this growth coming
from like what are people doing with
node why are they picking node we we
sort of figured out that there's this
new full stack emerging for applications
it's it's not just a front-end in the
backend anymore there's a lot of
environments that developers have to
grapple with to build a full application
so of course you like you still have web
front-ends people use web sites you
still have a cloud back-end like normal
like like we've had for forever but we
also have mobile and tablets we're also
now dealing still with desktop
applications I mean if you if you work
on anything that people use every day
and you have a distant location you know
that engagement is actually a lot higher
on desktop surprisingly
we have all these new API service layers
that you use pretty much virtually every
application out there now that gets
released also uses some third party API
service usually Twilio and then if this
wasn't complicated enough for all of us
to try and grapple with building an
application we have like a million IOT
devices that are all wildly incompatible
and horribly insecure so in order to
deal with this node is kind of the
perfect platform like we bring the web
and we bring accessibility and we bring
really ubiquity of the web platform and
of javascript to all these different
areas so you actually can use node in a
variety of different places among among
them relatively small team let's walk
through some of that real quick so web
front-end development so one for an
undeveloped has changed really
dramatically since I've started doing
web development like 15 years ago 20
years ago got him old okay so we started
building all these great tools in nodejs
and javascript to help you build
applications Babel four transpiling we
have linters we have a hint herbs
because there's a difference we have
dsls for a CSS we have all these great
tools to help you build out these
front-end in fact we have so many tools
then we wrote tools to manage all the
tools that you have an OD is to help you
with your application which is crazy but
now and then you have competing tools to
manage all the tools and then it ships
happened in front of development that I
I really didn't see coming which is that
web frameworks for the longest time have
been this thing that you put in a script
tag at the top of your site and then in
the rest of the site you use that API
it's accessible to you but then react
came along and it sort of rethought
about a web framework very very
differently it started to consider that
maybe where web framework should exist
is in this compiled chain where we have
access to node.js in this entire
ecosystem and this is like really a
binary shift like I don't think that
we're gonna see a lot of web frameworks
in the future written the old way
there's just so much you have access to
now and no js' to help you build out all
these tools now one of the nice things
about being a Microsoft is there's gonna
be examples throughout the entire stack
that Microsoft is actually invested in
which is kind of fun
so typescript is one of these examples
Microsoft is leading typescript they're
heavily invested in it
we've been arguing for years about
putting types in the language and then
Microsoft said we can add types just on
top with a compiled chain and it turns
out that this is actually kind of
preferable I mean I know that a lot of
people will still like to see it in
language but there are things that we
can do with this as a compile train and
as a tool you can't actually do if it's
just in the language itself which has
been really fun to watch and so type
scripts adoption is really growing
pretty fast okay so let's move along to
the next area we're gonna talk about
mobile a little bit so patchy Cordova
used to be called PhoneGap and then they
were getting sued by the gap I think for
trademark infringement which is
hilarious so when they went to do patchy
they changed their name to Cordova
because that's really easy to remember
and Cordova just brings the entire web
platform to iOS to Windows Phone to
Android right and it does this using
javascript using node like it's a node
tool chain it brings the entire node
ecosystem so now you get the node
ecosystem and all of the web platform
across all these different devices for
essentially like native applications
right um which is great it works great
on Windows Phone they've invested
heavily in that it's awesome okay so I
thought desktop was dead I thought that
we everything was a website now but
that's not true we people actually
really do want to build desktop
applications so github built this great
project called electron what electron
does is using the node ecosystem it
brings the web platform and the entire
node ecosystem to desktop development
for our sects for Linux and for Windows
of course the effect has been huge like
there's just been an explosion and
desktop applications using electron
everything from slack to my favorite
Visual Studio code this is one of those
things were like if I had a time machine
I would never be able to convince my
future self that I'd be using Visual
Studio in the future like that just
wouldn't ever happen but I've been on
this editor for a couple of years now
it's phenomenal like all the features
that people had an IDs that I wanted but
I didn't want to join 84 it has it's
great entirely built on electron using
node.js using the web platform so and
all of your applications if you build a
web application can really be easily
ported into a desktop application using
this entire notice
right all right moving along the cloud
so node was built for cloud services
it's always had a great cloud service
story
virtually every cloud provider sees a
lot of node adoption right now they have
pretty good node support we we do very
well here but I want to talk a little
bit more about Azure specifically
because from the moment that Asscher was
released they were talking to us in the
node.js community about how do we make
sure that this experience is really good
this is something that's been thought
about since day one this isn't an
afterthought and I know that you know a
lot of people the ways that come to
Azure is that they bring a lot of the
tool chains that they've been using in
the Windows platform into the cloud but
it's really important to note that from
day one a juror has really taken note
seriously and has a great node story
which will even talk a little bit more
when we come back to server less again
IOT because everybody wants a button to
do everything okay so starting in 2012
the node ecosystem started to see a big
rise in robots there were robot meetups
the node bots community kind of blew up
some of the people that used to work on
jQuery started building a framework for
building robots called johnny-five
and it is almost as easy as using jQuery
but you build robots it's awesome and so
this kind of hobbyist community really
grew from from 2012 on and as IOT
manufacturers started to bring new
device platforms online they started the
support node at first kind of as an
afterthought and then natively so
there's now like every new board that's
coming out as an integrated circuit for
people's IOT devices you're seeing like
first-class node support and every
single one of them because they know
that the best way to bring application
developers to their platform is to bring
the entire node ecosystem to their
platform as well and so this has been
really tremendous and not something that
we really saw coming you know even as
late as like you know 2014 we were
really seeing this okay so talk a little
bit specifically though about Windows 10
IOT because this is kind of cool
most other IOT platforms what they do is
they port v8 over to whatever crazy
architecture that there is a platform is
on
Microsoft didn't do that they already
have chakra running on these IOT devices
they're already optimizing chakra for
theirs ality devices why not just port
node to chakra crazy but they did it and
it works fantastic at first what they
did was they just emulated the entire v8
API via being the the VM that node is
usually bound to that is going to be
like impossible to maintain in the
future because v8 loves to break their
API and so what Microsoft did was they
they really got involved in the node
community and started working with us on
core and when we started to move towards
was what would it look like for node to
be truly VM neutral well we need in the
way and so Microsoft along with Google
and Mozilla have been working on an ADA
a new native layer in nodejs
that will separate it from being tightly
bound to the v8 API so even if you don't
care about node chakra even you don't
care about Windows IOT this is a huge
gift actually from the Microsoft team
because every major release of node we
break 30% of the packages in the node
ecosystem and that's just because the v8
ABI breaks every major release and so
everybody has to at least go and
recompile all of their native add-ons
it's a huge pain in the ass if any other
feature or bug fix was going to land a
node and it was gonna break 30% of the
ecosystem you never land that but just
because of the technical limitations
that we've been living under so long
we've just dealt with this starting in
node version 8 which is coming out in
like a month we have now experimental
support for this new native layer and
this native layer is going to allow us
to make real stability guarantees in the
future about the native ecosystem and so
we won't be breaking these api's in the
future and eventually node really will
be truly vm neutral which is fantastic
and I really can't stress enough like
how much Microsoft has led this effort
to get this in it's been awesome ok
closing out let's talk about api's so
yeah everybody uses api's in the cloud
now and if you've built a a new service
in the last couple of years I'm sure
that you use some kind of third party
API for doing something like I said
Twilio text messages are like the main
sample people love to do that but
literally everybody that puts up API
sees this huge amount of growth you know
moat I will go as far as to say most of
these were actually written in node but
now we're also moving into this like
serverless space where you actually
build your application out of these
discrete functions right there branding
it server list which is like the dumbest
branding ever but whatever I mean there
are servers they exist you're running on
them but you're basically looking at
these discrete functions that will that
will run your application you can build
it out of these smaller dynamic
components so the cool thing about this
is that every single one of these
vendors that's come out with the
solution has supported node first for a
little while some of them only supported
node and this because node is great for
this kind of use case for the longest
time we've been optimizing node for
running in a single process with a
limited memory space and just doing a
ton of i/o
we've been optimizing like the startup
performance because we just care about
that in our development cycle we want no
to start up quickly now it turns out
that these are like the most important
things for running in these cloud
function services because you need a
really fast startup timing to be really
efficient in a really small space
I mean Moore's Law still making
computers faster but somehow we keep
getting less and less of a slice of that
computer to actually run our
applications in and so it's been great
to see note on these including as your
function that your functions have great
support for nodejs they just did a bunch
of like new announcements like this week
I think about all the new great stuff
going in for no jss or functions so it's
been really cool the same so to wrap up
one of the things that I love about
working with nodejs
is that we're not just you know making
programming a little bit easier for
people that already know programming
when node comes into these spaces it
dramatically lowers the barrier to entry
for new developers coming to the space
and for new people learning and when you
start to tie all these together it means
that people that were not able to write
IOT like code for IOT devices before and
now have access to that and so we're
really like democratizing access to
build applications and making that more
accessible for more people and by tying
all this together we're now going to
open up
huge future industry - a lot of new
people and I love being a part of that
and I love like you know bringing the
web to everybody - more platforms to all
of you I really wish that every vendor
had a page like this so you can go to
Azure comp slash node and you can see
all the great things that you can use
note on on Azure I really wish that like
other local cloud vendors would do
something similar to this it really
helped talks like this but this is
fantastic everybody go check it out and
that's known everywhere thank you